[Applause]
what the oh my god what it's drew he
just posted a picture on facebook with
him and some girl no way y'all just
broke up yeah it's definitely been less
than a month
totals NASSCO how has he found someone
already I've only been on like one date
that's totally unfair
and that's not even his type how did it
get so many likes should I go out and
take a picture with the dude you should
like the picture like it uh what wait we
don't even know if he's dating the groom
we're jumping to conclusions he's
looking away from her oh but his hand
could be rubbing her back oh you can't
tell her knees are facing him
I see boredom in his eyes no conclusive
results maybe just a quick look at her
pitch
[Music]
no results except they think this is a
new year
Oh swim it are we being creepy maybe we
should stop girl no this is normal
yeah you're right yeah we gotta go
deeper
we're not the trip to Cabo we've already
been over the Cabo trip it's a dead end
but there are a lot of links in Jules
trip to Chicago
two years ago I know there are doesn't
make sense anymore this can't be the end
of the road I'm sorry but it is I quit
the taste you can't quit yes I have to
be pinging it like am i Lucy I need to
her mommy or daddy bear with me so many
bad memories don't give up
Drew's updated she has a boyfriend
mm-hmm he hasn't found love yet I'm
still ahead
not that it matters of course of course
not I mean you'd be totally happy for
him in a mature and classy kind of way
even if he won't stating somebody yeah
obviously well uh better you're going we
gotta get these suits back what for oh
right you know we're getting really good
[Music]